this movie is just so wild it's
everything I want in a Michael Bay film
what was it like shooting that car
chasing because I feel like that really
set the tone for what was to come for
this whole film endless yeah right I
mean we don't never about a month did
you really yeah you're in that car for
months but it was it was quite nice
because it was a it was what we first
started filming with and you have dave
franco ryan me and Melanie stuck in a
car and you're just bound to become
friends and and enjoy the rest of the
filming it was a really nice bonding I
think experience cuz we were all stuck
in this car going I don't even know how
many miles with a bunch of exposed
explosives we were all terrified 90% of
the time and excited another 10 I think
more than anything was like really
bonding for us she didn't get sick of
each other no I mean look Michael Bay
creates a kind of chaos on screen and
off screen I mean the way he shoots no
one ever knows what the hell's happening
it's all I guess in his head and in his
camera so yeah particularly this movie
is a very analog I mean it's like a
really incredible muscular spectacle
driven action movie and you know it's
kind of a return to form for Michael so
I think he was like really on edge and
really trying to deliver that sir stuff
but that sort of galvanizes the cast
like we don't really there's a lot of
chaos going on we all just get a lot
closer and this cast spent every every
day every night together even after work
we'd be having dinners and you know
drinks and that's great okay well not to
divide but if you had to choose one
person on your cast to be your right
hand in a gunfight who would you choose
you got some skills
yes like even in magnificent 70s like
anticipation turning and spinning I mean
he removed one from his prostate in the
middle of a shot very incredibly
dangerous things I don't recommend that
it's very he's a bad bad man
so no one would choose you know
absolutely man between Melanie and Manu
and I would go either way yeah ditto
I'd be Mike human shield you'd be hurt
human shield and then we just fought
through it you would eventually get me
to safety the most important thing at
the end of the day right you know when
you're on a set like this and these
scenes are so intricate you ever get
nervous like you're like I don't want to
mess up my line because there's a
million other explosions going off and I
don't want to ruin this scene is it like
that on set oh yeah I really like that
though now I do I or my career I I hate
that something like if there's a huge
explosion I'm supposed to say one line
and then the thing happens it all
happens in one shot yeah you've got one
this is it
I like that now I used to be terrified
of that yeah now it just makes it
interesting you think what happens do i
screw this up movie magic these days you
can fix anything
oh that's kind of job okay not to put
you on the spot but you were to Tom
Hanks in Greyhound yeah is that true so
you have to settle the debate who's the
nicest guy in Hollywood Tom or Ryan go
ahead tell fine you can say me no but
it's they're both amazing yeah I gave
you full permission to say me matter
beyond it hey give me a break the same
planet you're going both and I have
Ariana hates mix ice cream look like
murder very nice man
it's a debate on light we had to settle
it now we know both thank you very much